how does
it feel until it feels very cool
the truth is that we had rented for
so many years and finally that we already
own our own house the truth is
that if a euro feels so big
especially if not so young- this since
we can  To have this space for
our daughters says the Swiss
the programs the options for you
because of the situation in which
the legal status is and yours you wanted to see
what was the best solution the best
way
it is like that I think many especially
our community we think it is very expensive
There are limitations, I don't have status, but
sometimes there are programs that exist and
assistance that can help you,
so the one who doesn't ask isn't
really, that's super important to
inform you. The worst question is the one that is
n't asked, so I'm going to be with myself and
with  the striker company had a
thousand questions what is this that is of
interest what will happen to it if we decide to
sell this is a huge report
especially as I tell m  My husband
at that time when we just started
that process I had Hayden we only knew
that we had to see a
different process but I have only
questions the answer will always be
the same
we have a dream we want to live in a
certain way and right now I will show you  my
horses from the little animals and it was something
that we had a vision for
our life I had a vision of how to
create my daughters in the environment and well
in an apartment where they can't even
play outside it was not the vision I
had for  my family then was more
than anything the desire to want more and to
move a little differently
and when we got to the house that is, it was
completely different the old
floor you could say this is a
bigger older mosquito house but
I knew it was  a potential
so you can't focus on what it doesn't have
or you can focus the potential on what you
can do with the opportunity so
I said well it's in the  The opportunity
to build our first home is something, it
's a huge step compared to
where we lived before, so I saw it
as a house that has a lot of
potential. We completely redid all
the bathrooms, the kitchen, the floors, the
walls, that is, we literally closed in
August and didn't enter.  to the house
until October after having done all
the renovation so it was so nice to be
able to enter what was to your liking in
your style and well here we are
and now a little bit about what
it means
since I arrived
financial if you want  be the space
you should
because it is something that can go, it
happens it
is some type of investment that can be
continued
many times when you do not rent you feel
safe, right that you are making your
payments you are sure there are limitations but
that is not satisfied but when you have
your  The house is yours it is yours
tomorrow if you rent the owner decides to
sell his house and they take you out or something happens and
the owner loses the house and can be  er this
vector is true and when I study you know
that you are working for something that
will be yours from your family from your children
so it is a dream that especially
as a native it is not true that
we always seek the American dream this is
part of that American dream  When it is addressed
that you can get to this country,
working is part of it and having that reward
for your effort and being able to enter your house
and see that with your effort you achieved
it feels very very cool and as I tell you,
no one can take it away from you, study and
comparison when  rent the
limitations you are like those who are
paying someone else when many
times and due to lack of knowledge you can
even pay the same by renting and that
owning your own fit is your own
home are many people do not know that
and limit themselves
in the box and  Now I say my little
ranch and for less than 500 dollars, what
do you say, well, I am not true if you have
allowed me that it is the limiting thought to
what is fair in this area, the truth is then
It's not much of a jump, it's not like a class
for thousands, it's more true to me, but how will
you know if you never risk
doing it?